hello everybody this is peter cooper
from the ncbi
um welcome to today's webinar which is
going to be about an update on
ncbi password retirement i'll go ahead
and turn it over to
kimberly pearl who is the product owner
for my ncbi
uh take it away kimberly thanks peter hi
everybody um as peter mentioned my name
is kimberly pearl
i'm the product owner for my ncbi and
today i'm going to
give you an update on the password
retirement timeline
and give you a demo of our password
retirement wizard
so first i want to go over what we mean
when we say password retirement for
those of you who aren't sure
when we say password retirement we mean
that the password that you use to create
your my ncbi account
is going away so what that means is
you'll need to log in going forward
using a third party login that is linked
to your my ncbi account
it's just the password that's going away
nothing's happening with the account
itself
some examples of third-party logins are
era commons login.gov which is available
to you whether or not you're in the us
it's available to anybody orcid
google microsoft live and this means
your personal outlook or hotmail.com
account
um or you may be able to log in through
your
educational or research organization
if they're members of the in common or
edu gain organizations
we do have a url here um to our ncbi
insight blog transition tips page so if
you'd like some
extra guidance on which third party
login
um may be good for you you can go to
that link and take a look
alright so an update on the retirement
timeline
on june 22nd we disabled the ability to
create ncbi accounts with ncbi passwords
so that's no longer possible and then on
july 6
we launched our password retirement
wizard as an opt-in experience and what
that means is
we have a url you can go to the url
and retire the password for your account
at any time
that's convenient for you later this
summer
we'll be launching the wizard as opt-out
and what that means is when you try to
log into your account you'll be
redirected
to the wizard and asked to retire your
password at that time
for the opt-in and opt-out phases of
this there is an update
later button that you'll see in the demo
so
if you decide that you don't want to
retire your password at that time you
can click
update later you'll be taken to the my
ncbi page and you can continue what
you're doing
mid to late fall though we will be
making the wizard mandatory
so that means that when you log in
you'll
be shown the wizard you'll have to go
through and
retire your password before you'll be
able to access
your my ncbi account and then in june
2022
uh any accounts that have active
passwords
those passwords will be disabled um
and if you would like to access your my
ncbi account and you don't have a third
party login linked to it that you can
log in with
you'll have to go through a process to
recover
access to your accounts i just want to
stress here that
your account isn't going away it'll
still be there
it's just that if you haven't linked
your third-party login
you just won't be able to access it at
that time
all right so does this apply to you
in your account well it only applies to
you
if you have an ncbi password
there are many accounts out there where
they
register where people registered their
accounts using a third party login and
that's how
they log in and they don't have ncbi
passwords for those people
you'll never see the wizard you don't
even have to think about it you're good
to go
um if you're not sure whether or not you
have an ncbi password
it's easy to find out one is if that's
what you're using to log in obviously
you have one
but once you're logged in if you click
on your username you can go to your
account settings page
and one clue here is if your username
is not an email address or not your era
commons or orcid id
odds are pretty good that you do have a
password
so on the account settings page you're
going to go to the ncbi
account section and if you do have a
password the help
test text will tell you that um your
username and password is maintained by
ncbi
and you'll see the word password here
with some asterisks and there'll be a
button so you can change your password
everyone who has this in their account
they'll need to
go through the wizard and retire their
passwords
if you created your account with a third
party login
when you go to that same section the
help text will tell you
that you log in via third party account
you'll just have your username here
no password and you'll see that
you have your third party linked here
for the one with the password just to
know you
this one does have a third-party login
link to it
but that doesn't mean you don't have to
go through the wizard we still have to
retire your password even if you have
your third party
link to it all right
so now the debt wizard demo so
one question i've gotten is why is there
a wizard at all
why aren't we just retiring the
passwords and
making instead making people sort of go
through this process
well the answer is we really want to
make sure that you
keep access to your account and it's as
seamless as possible
and so the wizard has two goals and the
main goal
is to make sure that you can log into
your account via third party login
and then once we make sure that you can
do that
we retire your password um
so we just want to make sure that if you
don't have a third-party login linked we
do that for you
and if you do you verify that you can
log in with it because
even though there are accounts where
people have their third party
um logins linked to it we have no good
way of knowing whether or not
you still have access to that third
party so we're going to verify that
um so without further ado i'll move on
to the demo
i'm going to show you three scenarios
the first one is an account that has no
third-party logins linked
and by far this is most of the accounts
um then i'm going to show you
an account that has at least one third
party login linked where we're going to
verify that
that we can log in with it and then i'm
going to show you
the quickest way through the wizard
which is
you still have an active ncbi password
but you log in with your third-party
login
all right okay so i'm going to go to the
wizard
and i'm going to log in with my ncbi
credentials
and again this is with an account that
doesn't have
any third party logins linked to it
okay so here's the intro page as i
mentioned there's an
update later button if for whatever
reason you've started this and realize
you're not ready to do it
and you'll notice that it is telling you
what the username is of the account that
we're retiring the password for
so i'm going to click next
and we have step one of two which is
adding a new way to login this is where
we're going to
link a new third-party login to your
account
i will note here that we strongly
suggest that you have your third-party
user name and password available before
you continue you have that account
created
you know how to log into it it'll make
things very smooth as we go forward
so i'm going to click on add a new way
to log in
and then i'm going to pick the third
party
that has the account that i'm going to
link so in this case
i'm going to pick microsoft
and i'm going to log into
my microsoft account
and it's going to think a little bit
and then it's going to take me back to
the wizard so
we have successfully linked
that microsoft outlook.com account
to my ncbi account with that username
and now i'm just going to confirm that i
understand
that when i click the confirm button
my ncbi password is going to be retired
so i'm going to click that
click confirm and bam you're all set
your account has a retired password
you're good to go there's nothing else
that you need to do
if you want to read more you can visit
our faq and there's that tips page i
mentioned
earlier you hit exit
and that takes you to your account
settings so
you'll see that i have
the retired here where it says password
and that it's linked to my microsoft
live account while i'm here just quickly
i want to show you that
you can add other third-party
logins to your account if you want a
couple of different ways to log
in and this is available right now even
before you retire your password
um i can't link another microsoft live
account but i could
search for and link another type like
orcid
or if i wanted to link my
institution account i could do that but
you will note that since the password is
retired
it will not let you remove
the last third party login that's linked
to the account
otherwise you would have no way to log
in
okay so i'm going to move on to scenario
two
i just close out so that i have a fresh
browser
and for this one um this account
has a third party link to it and i'm
going to log
in with my ncbi username and password so
i click on my account
paste in the username
password okay
intro screen again going to click next
and this time the wizard knows that i
have
a third party linked here so i'm just
going to verify it
just to note if you get to the screen
and there's a third party log
in here that you don't have access to
you can always choose this option saying
you don't have access to it and you want
to
add a new one and it'll just take you to
linking another
third party the way that we just showed
you but for this i'm just going to
verify the one that's already here
uh
and it's going to think a little bit and
redirect back
to the wizard and again it's confirmed
that we know that you can log in with
the
link third party i understand my
password is retiring
i'm going to hit confirm
and it is dropping me off at my ncbi
account
if we go into the settings you'll see
the passwords retired um
it's linked i'm currently signed in via
my google account i'm good to go
um one thing i'll show you
if i sign out of this
and if i try to log in again
it'll throw an error saying that the
password has been retired
all right so i'm gonna get another fresh
browser
and go on to the final scenario so
you may have noticed if you've seen
communication from us
this past year that we've been
encouraging everybody to get this third
party link to their account
and i want to encourage you further
when you sign in to start getting used
to signing in with your
um third-party login because this is by
far
the easiest way through this with wizard
so i am going to log in directly
with the third party account that is
linked
the login that's linked to my ncbi
account
so we'll get the intro screen again
to make sure that nobody surprised and
then but when i click next
we go straight to hey confirm that
you're ready to retire
your password because we've already
verified that you can log in with your
third-party login so i'm going to click
i understand confirm
everything's set the password has been
retired for this
and then you exit out and you get your
account settings
so that's it it's pretty simple if you
have
your um third-party login information
ready to go it's a it's a pretty
painless process
in general
so that's all i had today as far as the
demo but i'm happy to answer some
questions if there are
there are any questions out there
yeah hi kimberly this is peter um we do
have a lot of questions in here
uh some of them okay they're pretty
technical and
i think um sherry has answered a bunch
of them in the
one common one that seems to be showing
up a bit is about the issue of linking
more than one third-party account
and also like you know one example is
suppose i'm at an institution
say a university i'm using that login
but when i retire
you know what should i do if i want to
use a different login how should i do
that
yep that's a really great great question
and the answer to that
is before you lose access
to your institution account that you're
logging in with
you'll want to go into your account
settings
and um link a new third-party account
so i'm logged in here right now i have
google
but let's say i want to but let's
pretend that this is my
nih account and i want to link um an
orcid account
a login gov.com or my
gmail account so i keep access to it
all you have to do i i did that fast but
let me
let me go back and do it again
is under linked accounts click change
it's thinking it's a little tired today
apparently
and then search for the third party you
want to add
so if it's orcid
or if it's login.gov
which is right here then you can link
that to your account too
and then you can log in using any of the
accounts that you have linked
what else okay well i know
we don't want to get into too deep about
this but you know
a lot of people are there's a lot of
people asking about you know this
is what they're calling security
concerns from google and just want to
point out that you can always use
login.gov if you're concerned about
using logins from google and things like
that so there is another way to do this
is there anything you want to say about
that no i think you covered it peter
i think our recommendation is if you if
you have concerns about
google which we have heard we do have
other options
we generally tell people who don't want
to use google hey
use login.gov it's secure anyone can use
it
it has two-factor authentication um
and link that to your account and just
use that
yeah and so can you clarify a little bit
more about somebody asked specifically
what is login.gov do you have
can you give a brief sort of
introduction to what that is
um well it's just at a high level
login.gov is an initiative
by the us government to have
one account that you can use to log in
to multiple
us government services and ncbi happens
to be one of those services that it
supports
so you create your login.gov account and
then you can use that to log into ncbi
you can
use it to log into other um
government agencies that are supported
and there's a list if you go to
login.gov there's a list of
what agencies are supported but it's
basically they wanted a
essentially a single sign-on account
that you can use for multiple things and
and like i mentioned it's available to
anyone you don't have to be a us citizen
or even in the u.s to use it
and so this has come up a little bit in
a couple of different questions
about and i don't completely understand
this and maybe there's too much
technical detail to go into for
everybody but there seems to be this
they're moving yuri commons to be a
login.gov
um login and how does that affect
the way that you will log into my ncbi
if you use ericom so yeah so that's
um i don't have the full details about
that
um but our current recommendation
is to go to era
and log in and come to ncbi
from era um that seems to
work the best i know we do have
um something in progress we're investing
investigating a way to make that a
little more intuitive for you guys and
i'll make sure that
we update our faq with more information
when i have it
but yeah it was unfortunate timing for
us and or them to have both of these
transitions at the same time
and i'm trying to figure out a way to
make it a little bit more intuitive in
terms of how that
impacts how you're logging in but the
the short answer is
if you have an era account that's tied
to a login.gov account
you can definitely um log into
ncbi it's just um the part that's not
entirely clear to me right now
is um if you can
log in to your login.gov that's
associated to your
era account by going directly to ncbi
and then we know that it's tied to the
era account
so i'm i'm definitely looking into that
um presently and we'll make sure that
there's more info
on the um faq for you and
yeah that's great and also um
sherry has put some sort of detailed
answers that i don't completely
understand
but if you're she would know if you use
this process they will probably
make perfect sense to you if you have a
question about your comments and
everybody should be able to see those
answers because she sent them to
everyone
a couple of people have said that that
the wizard doesn't seem to be active
for them is that the case it's not
active for everybody yet
if you go to that url you should be
getting the wizard
what may happen though is it may ask you
to log in
before you see the intro screen so i'm
not sure
what what it means when they say it's
not active for them
if if one of you can sort of write in
with what you're seeing
that would be great um and you can all
go ahead and here's an example okay
someone says i don't get the wizard pop
up when i log in with my ncbi
credentials
but they do have a third party link but
it's not my primary
okay okay so what that means is that's
the
opt out portion um and we haven't
launched it opt out yet
let me go back to the timeline we've
launched it opt-in so what that means is
you have to go
to the url in order to see the wizard
it's not
going to pop up for you until later this
summer
so you're gonna go to
account.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov forward slash
migrate
and then you'll see the wizard so that
would be where they should go
if they want if they want to go ahead
and
get this over with and do whatever they
need to do to
yeah yep and i i really recommend it
because if you're if you do it now um
then you don't even have to
you want to have it pop up you won't
have to worry about it
sort of interrupting what you do later
you can just retire your password
log in with your third party and forget
about it
so i'll do another easy one and then
okay a hard one uh so uh
someone just wants to know about your
demo did you use three different ncbi
accounts for the three demos
i did um just to make it easier because
um
you know once you retire the password
the password is retired
okay uh and this one may be again
something that has to be
dealt with uh in more technical detail
but uh someone has you know many
libraries do this they use easy proxy
for journal access
and they recommend people use orcid
so far they have not been able to set up
the process going to pubmed via the
proxy server and then to orcid login and
then to pub that again without losing
the easy proxy connection
so maybe that's something that needs to
be addressed in you know
by our help desk yeah that
that would be my suggestion i do know
that in some cases
um turning off the proxy logging in and
then turning it back on has worked
um i i don't know that that works a
hundred percent of the time but
that's a quick workaround otherwise if
you are encountering that
issue please write into the help desk
and we will see what we can do
okay yeah that's a that's a question
that a couple of people have
asked and sherry has put that into the
to the questions pod to it
if you need help you'll see on the slide
that
kimberly has displayed right now write
to us at info so you know
info ncbi.nlm.nih.gov if there's some
question that
is very specific or it's something that
we haven't gotten to today and you need
an answer right away please you know
write to us
and we have a team of people that are
dedicated to answering
questions about my ncbi and so they'll
get they'll get you the right answer as
fast as possible
yep they're a great team
well one simple one that's not to take
me too long to read it
can you uh attach the same third party
login to more than one line tbi account
good question the answer is no because
that is your any
unique identifier for that account
so you can you can attach the same
account to
one ncbi account and
you can only attach what the
what's the best way to say this you can
only attach one
third-party account from each third
party
yeah i think this is the same question
basically if you already have an ncbi
account
on the third-party log and i want to
attach to my ncbi native account
and you'd have to merge the two accounts
um
how would you what's the process for
merging the two accounts and
and how does that go with you
yep that's a great question i recommend
you write into the help desk if you'd
like to merge your accounts
um for a couple of reasons one
if you have submission data there's a
sort of a separate behind the scenes
process to get your submission data
merged and um our
our help desk people can get that
initiated and get everything ready to go
before your accounts are actually
emerged
the other thing is generally when you
merge you have a primary and a secondary
account and most things
um merge but some things the primary
value
is what saves so like your my your my
bibliography
public url would be for your primary
account so
um but if you write into the help desk
they would be happy
to help you manage the merge process
okay so here's another question and i
think it it's uh
it addresses sort of a misconception so
somebody said
it would be accurate to tell their
patrons that they can use their current
ncbi
account only until mid late fall when
their accounts will be retired
that's not true at all the accounts are
not being retired at all
so the accounts are not being retired
it's only the passwords that are being
retired correct
yes and i'm so glad that this came up
because i really want that to be clear
we're not doing anything with the
accounts themselves
all we're doing is we're updating the
way that you log
into the account so as long as you have
a third party login linked to the
account
um you can still use your account and
log in via that
third party yes thanks it's just like
any sort of a lot of the things that
people log into
like you know say you use spotify or
something you can log in with
your native credentials or you can log
in with facebook or whatever so
it's just we're losing the the native
password that's all
yep so here's another one um
if it's in tbi considering making it
possible to log in on the same account
from multiple devices and seeing a
recent activity
is that something that doesn't exist now
i guess it is so
i don't really understand the question i
mean
if you're using a different browser so a
different device you
you have to log in on each device but
what you see in your account should
be the same no matter what device you're
logging into
okay all right that makes sense to me um
i'll address the last question before i
address one before which is
yes so somebody asked will transcript of
the questions being typed into the chat
box and their answers be available after
the webinar
absolutely so that's one of the things
we're definitely going to do we probably
won't
get all these questions that when we do
that it's not going to be verbatim
because
many of these questions are pretty much
asking the same thing so we'll sort of
consolidate them
and give you know one answer
um but we should get that available as
soon as we can so it'd probably be about
a week or so before we give that up
it's going to be in that ftp directory
that i had the um
compressed link on the first slide
okay here's another one if a patron uses
login.gov and supplies their school
email address will our library's
ft icons appear when they log in um
i actually don't know the answer to this
one
i would assume that if they're seeing
the icons now then they
when they log in they still should but i
i've actually never heard of the
scenario
okay so we'll take a look at that when
we get when we compile the answers to
these questions
so here's one that um maybe you can
provide some information on or maybe
that's something that we don't really
want to get into too much because it's
really a personal decision i think but
what are the pros and cons for each of
the different third-party logins
yeah so we have put together some
guidance for you
on our tips page and that link is um in
a couple places in the
slide presentation um that are based on
sort of what you do when you log in to
ncbi
so we have some guidance for people who
are using ncbi accounts primarily for
grant applications
um we have guidance for
researchers or clinicians
students or educators and it's basically
um like for grant application it makes
sense right era
nsf login.gov these are um
these are directly well era and national
science foundation
are directly related to science tv and
submitting grants
and login.gov is as we mentioned before
you know the official u.s government
account so those are really great
choices
um researchers if you have an organ
account
that one um makes the most sense it
goes with you from institution to
institution it's tied directly to
you as a researcher it makes a lot of
sense but
you know you can also use your
institution um or these other
recommendations
um so and and really um
there's aside from
like the grant um application process
and things like that
the the options the they're
very similar it's really about what
you're comfortable with
so if you prefer to have your account
tied to the institution
that you're working at that's tied to
the work you're doing at ncbi then that
makes a lot of sense
if you prefer to be more anonymous you
could
um create a
google account or a login.gov account
with any sort of name that you wanted to
and use that
um if you want your account tied to
your research and the work you're doing
and have all of that
and import stuff from orcid for example
into your bibliography you could use
orchid
um and you know as someone mentioned
earlier in the questions there are some
people who
can't use or are not comfortable with
using something like google
so that's when maybe login.gov would be
a good option for you
thank you kimberly it's good that you
showed this document because i think
it's useful for people to see it
and we'll keep adding stuff to these
kinds of you know the q a
and the transition tips so i think we
should probably just wrap up for today
and we'll address these questions
um in the document yup thanks everybody
really appreciate you being here
definitely want to hear from you if you
have any questions thanks everybody
and thanks for coming
you